[Music]
I'm scared to go with the shops when I
see kids standing outside of it like
proper proper scared especially if one
of them has a bike and a tracksuit
so the fear surrounding these films is
very relatable today juxtaposed in this
we begin to see Batman's positive
influence on youth Harry Kelly Don's a
Robin costume and takes off into the
night similar to the first night that
Bruce returned as Batman it's a
triumphant moment that really captures
the embodiment of youth in the world
ermine are just throwing yourself into
something headfirst it's full of
mischief and acts as a brilliant way to
introduce the character she really
stands out amongst all the grade and you
can definitely see why Bruce would
confide in her as his new ward I think
this moment actually went on to
influence clocks flying in Man of Steel
acts as a beautiful and graceful telling
of finding one's feet similar to that
film Batman's legacy and inspiration is
felt throughout the city both positively
and negatively in this issue we see a
man dressed as Batman attempt to murder
someone it's clear that The Legend of
the bat can be taken either way and once
the Caped Crusader's morality is black
and white it's nice to see that his
inspiration is covered in shades of grey
and add to depth of the book that
several comics are enabled to capture
and elevates it to a new height set in
the background of this issue is the
tales of Gothamites they paint a clearer
picture of just how ruthless and
terrorizing the Gotham mob is and it
works in building tension towards the
climax we get an astounding one-shot
this is around a woman being murdered on
her way home from work it's a really
touching moment in which upon des about
the odd set that she's bought for a son
and how it will allow him to go on to be
a great artist it's just silly little
things that we as people think of just
to get it through those tough days so
it's completely devastating when a
mutant hood grabs a person puts a
grenade in it killing her if she finally
wrestles back the purse from him it
really paints a bleak tone to the city
and it heightens Batman's importance and
stopping this threat
it's one of Miller's best depictions of
some nefarious evil villains it's the
complete polar opposite to Hobley terror
let's put it that way there's also an
eerie tailing which someone shoots at
the cinema this harrowing Lee you would
be echoed in real life at the premiere
of The Dark Knight Rises and it adds a
somber tone now heightened reality of
mr. booth making it more relevant today
than it was thirty years ago the
Batmobile draws down the streets take
the mutant leader head-on designing this
is completely alien to what had come
before not to a tank it really feels
like a firm inable vehicle that will add
credit to the fact that the police have
never been able to stop Batman
it gives clear inspiration to Batman
Begins and the Nolan verse due to its
uniqueness and feeling of sheer power
Batman could easily take down the
meatman leader in this tank but when the
criminal towards Batman you simply
cannot ignore it you do his death wish
he just leaps out and begins to fight
him head on I think he has this need to
prove to himself that he's still the man
he used to be it's very bold he goes
against the stronger man and you badly
badly uses it really adds a human side
to the dog Knight that is a far cry from
the invincible man that once was I love
how this is a real learning curve for
Batman that massively would go on to
enforce how prepared he has to be in his
later fights like batman the reader has
given a real learning curve on the
brashness of courage and how facing
things head-on isn't always the smartest
choice
as our bodies deteriorate with age we
must seek wisdom and this is clearly
painted out by the fact that Batman must
become smarter in this world to survive
the meeting lead and also a clear Bane
prototype acts as a fulfilling burn for
the Dark Knight Batman only makes it out
the fight with the help of Carrie Kelly
and this is where the two thirds
interact with one another whilst the
majority of this book is timeless the
slang of the gang news isn't it's very
very dated terms like me know Billie and
leader no shoe or completely laughable
these days it's like when an panel tries
to write kid dialogue in a film even
though they've not seen one in 20 years
because of their restraining order those
sick sick bastards but I digress it
really puts the book firmly in the
eighties like when you watch the
Terminator 2 and there's that ginger kid
with the mullet the one who should have
been terminated in the first trimester
at least that kid wasn't wearing a
t-shirt with my name is rock written on
it which Rob I'm guessing is it's that
bad and really knocks this issue down a
peg every time you read it luckily
that's the only fault I can really give
it lead in the mutant leader back to the
pit Batman brakes the beast of a man and
the mutant gang in the process even on
my 10th 20th however many read-throughs
it's been because I've got no life this
still stands as a blazing example of the
importance of symbology Batman destroys
the group by humiliating their leader to
the point that they no longer want to be
associated with him and instead follow
the Dark Knight's example people will
forever follow strong leadership and
it's a very cerebral way to defeat a
legion of people without ever having to
lay a finger on them I absolutely love
this turn in the booth and operates as
one of the best final showdown
so the Dark Knight Returns good too
avoids the sophomore cursed slightly it
paints a broad picture of the legacy
that Batman's gonna leave behind
eventually when he does retire and
showcases wine mythology is still so
important today well so don't think that
Miller's artwork in this issue is as
strong as the first one and some of the
dialogue sounds like it was written by a
trunk about 10 minutes down the script
in so we just scribbled down some of the
stuff that kids we might say the fukes
still stands the test of time and that's
why I'm giving it a 9 so what do you
think of the Dark Knight Returns with
two and do you think it still holds up
the quality that the first one had
comment below let me know if you like
the mutant leader as well reading Geordi
LaForge sunglasses I'm reviewing all of
the dog that returns franchise boots in
the lead up to my review of The Dark
Knight 3 the master race so make sure
you subscribe my channel to keep up to
date with my thoughts on every single
issue and poop thanks very much for
checking out this video and hopefully
I'll see you next time take care
[Music]